hi gang my name is Matias and I work on
Chrome today I'd like to highlight a
handy little JavaScript performance
trick that's a little bit surprising and
somewhat counterintuitive JavaScript
applications and in particular web apps
commonly use large objects to represent
state or other data the example we're
looking at right now is fairly simple
and small but on the web it's
surprisingly common to see objects of
several kilobytes in size especially for
web apps built using frameworks such as
react or Redux unfortunately web apps
often depend on this data for their
initial render in such cases this large
JavaScript object ends up on the
critical path and so users end up
staring at a blank screen until all of
this data is loaded parsed compiled and
executed by the JavaScript engine how
can web developers make this faster one
approach is to use server-side rendering
you surf plain HTML that already
contains the processed form of the data
and therefore no JavaScript is required
for the initial load of your app this
way you can avoid the need for the large
JavaScript objects entirely but what if
you can't use server-side rendering is
there anything else we can do to improve
performance it depends in many cases
this critical data doesn't contain
anything that cannot be unambiguously
represented in JSON there's no date
objects no begins no Maps no sets and so
on and in those cases instead of having
an object literal in the JavaScript
source code you can serialize the object
as JSON turn it into a JavaScript string
literal and then pass that to the built
in JSON dot parse function this
technique produces an equivalent object
now which of these two techniques do you
think is faster as it turns out the JSON
approach is significantly faster this is
a little surprising and counterintuitive
the JavaScript object literal feels like
the more direct approach whereas JSON
dot parse feels like an additional layer
of indirection yet somehow json dot
parse is much faster
why is that part of the reason is that
for JavaScript engines the JSON example
is super simple to scan and parse think
of it this way to the JavaScript parser
this code snippet is little more than a
call expression with a single argument
the large blob of data is just a single
string literal token on the other hand
the equivalent object literal consists
of many more tokens each property name
is an identifier token or a string like
literal and in this case each of the
values is a numeric literal but they
could really be anything they could be
nested objects or arrays with properties
and values of their own in which case
there's even more tokens so compared to
the JSON that parse example the
JavaScript parser needs to work harder
just to tokenize the script correctly
another reason why javascript object
literals are harder to scan and parse is
because you don't know ahead of time
that their object literals let's unpack
that a little bit
pretend you're a parser for a minute and
you're looking at source code character
by character in JSON as soon as you see
an opening brace there's only two
possible options either this is the
start of an object or this is invalid
JSON two options that's it in JavaScript
however there's many more possibilities
an opening brace could be the start of
an object literal but it could also be a
number of other things let's walk
through some examples here we have an
opening brace on the second line what do
you think is this an object literal or
not and what does the X on the second
line refer to does it refer to the
binding on the first line or is it
something else turns out it's not even
possible to answer these questions
without looking at the rest of the code
in this case the second line creates an
object literal X refers to the binding
on the first line but in this case it's
an object structuring and the X doesn't
refer to the first line at all and then
there's this scenario where the second
line contains an arrow function with a
destructuring parameter
named X in that case the ax also does
not refer to the first line the point
I'm trying to make here is that parsing
JavaScript is tricky because its grammar
is context-sensitive
JSON doesn't have that problem and so
parsing JSON is much simpler and that's
why especially for large objects it's
faster to use JSON dot parse than to use
a JavaScript object literal at this
point you're probably wondering how much
faster is it exactly we measured this
for an 8 megabytes payload on cold loads
with no caching and found that in v8 and
Chrome the JSON of parse technique is
1.7 times as fast as the object literal
and the speed-up applies to other
JavaScript engines and browsers as well
in Safari and javascriptcore the
difference is even greater there
Jason look bars is twice as fast okay
you might say that's just a synthetic
benchmark with a very large payload how
does this affect real-world web apps
well henrik eurotech applied this
optimization to a redux app he was
working on and published a case study
about the results
there was an 18 percent improvement in
time to interactive and the apps
lighthouse performance score went up
eight points as well that's not bad for
applying a single optimization how can
you start making use of this
optimization
I wouldn't recommend doing this manually
in source code you still want to use
object literals since they're just more
readable
instead tooling can help you to
automatically transform large object
literals into JSON table bars as a build
time optimization web pack already
applies the JSON but barse technique if
your code base uses JSON modules there's
also a babel plugin that can apply the
transformation on other code for more
JavaScript performance tips check out
the cost of JavaScript on the v8 blog
and that's it thanks for watching
everyone
[Music]